this
is the very first time that bands are
playing on the street during the berlin
music week
it's a great opportunity for bands such
as hey moon shaker
to get some live exposure that's
important because musicians
seldom earn money from the internet for
me for instance i'm more involved in the
performance side of things
where that's where the real income comes
from i mean
with streaming we're living inside a
generation where
everything's available for free like so
you can't expect it's just the way it is
so
this is where the money starts in the
music business today
through streaming services such as wimp
music
the norwegian company is already
established in much of europe
and is now moving into the united states
the pop music site hopes to eventually
attract jazz and classical music fans
a limp music subscription costs 240
euros per
year it's a lot of money and most of it
goes to the record companies
like most streaming services we give up
to 70 percent of our sales to the record
labels
it depends on the deal we have with the
label but it's between 65 and 70 percent
we can't give them any more and we
cannot dictate how much gets back to the
artists
but in queensland
that's why the internet is a bad way for
musicians to make money
most of the money from streaming goes to
the labels and internet companies
each time a song is streamed the artists
earn less than one cent
so concerts are more important than ever
there is extraordinary pressure in the
live concert business these days
that's because nobody is earning as much
through cd sales or streamings as they
used to
instead you have to make all your money
during summer music festivals
but even live concerts hardly bring any
cash to newcomer bands
a number of music events are taking
place along with the berlin music
week and in most of them bands are
playing for free
their hope is to generate a large
following on the internet
and eventually that elusive record deal
you